hello and welcome everyone to a nother a
pack developer office hours so for those
of you guys that are joining us for the
first time this is your opportunity to
join us live and ask us questions on
Android development you also have the
opportunity to post questions on Google
moderator so if you go to the plus
android developers google+ page you'll
see this particular event and you'll be
able to go follow the the link to
developers google.com / live you'll see
our event there and there's a moderator
page at the bottom of that event page so
you can post some questions and we
answer them live so let me introduce our
team for today firstly we have onion
woods diwani from Hyderabad hey guys
then we have tony chen joining us from
hong kong hello everyone and i am Ankur
Kotwal and i'm joining in from Sydney
Australia so unfortunately we weren't
able to run a hangout last week so there
was a bit of a gap but I'm really glad
you could join us today and we can
resume normal scheduling so we've we've
got a number of questions that have been
posted to to the to the Google moderator
page and we're just going to go through
them one by one let us try and do
something a little bit tricky and share
our our page the moderator page let's
see if we can get that to happen and so
let me go screen share and Android apac
office hours cool I can see that
excellent good stuff so well this is
last week's one so that's a little bit
of icing let me let me flick to to this
week's one and do the screen share again
apologies for that
alright so here we are so let's just go
through these one by one the first one
is from ryan from Edmonton Tony would
you like to take this one yeah sure so
what is the best practice recommend
recommended method for implementing push
notification in the enterprise apps
specifically so we have something called
c2dm and now we officially launched it
in google i/o of what we now call Google
Cloud messaging so so it's a really
reliable way to do push notifications so
we have documentation on our website and
I think give you google GCM or google
com messaging you you should be able to
find the documentation cool doing that
and I think glass don't go okay so um I
guess anyway you can take the second
question before um okay I think I think
I'm good I'm good my apologies for the
car I actually don't know what happened
but I'm back so next question my
question last week was not about the io
2012 app but the issue on the spinner
the app is an example showing us that it
is not working with the source code
provided to us may I have a follow-up
this week so just some context about
that last week we had we had a question
about using the spinner in the action
bar so you know the content control and
patient with the viewpager hi there
Andrew hey how's it going hey good thank
you so formally had had raised some
questions about basically saying when I
use my my spinner the the spinner
drop-down will change pages
but when I actually swipe across pages
it doesn't update the spinner for me so
I need do you want to take this one yeah
so I think the viewpager is not wired up
to spinner so that the viewpager events
are propagated back to spinner so
there's one thing you can do is you can
try obtaining the so when you swipe and
move to a certain fragment you can try
obtaining the the item from the spinner
adapter which is basically what's
backing up the spinner can try obtaining
that fragment from the spinner adapter
the position of their fragment and then
manually called spinner dot said
selection and provide that position to
the spinner so I think that should
change up the spinner view but you may
want to check if the event is again
fight back and tries to again you know
switch to that fragment in that case you
can overwrite that I went to say hey
it's a swipe so don't really change the
fragment fair enough thank you hey
Andrew so we since since you're here
live did you have any questions for us
before we move on to add what's Dana
office car listening and today okay no
worries I'll just screen share again the
the set of questions so I'm he had also
asked us some questions last week and we
didn't have the questions the answers
available for him live at the time so I
i asked him afterwards to post them on
the moderator so that we could answer
them that in the the next office hours
so let's look at his question he said
first but thanks for the follow up on
this he had two questions what is the
optimal way to get the existing fragment
from a view pager it's question number
one and question number two is what is
the difference between a few animator
and a view flipper okay so first
question what's the optimal way to get
the existing fragment from the viewpager
the viewpager can actually give you you
can get the ID of your fragment from the
viewpager that's the one that's
currently being displayed and then you
can use your fragment manager to
basically go and pull that pull
in itself now I remember Abby had also
had some questions around well if I've
already instantiated a bunch of
fragments how do I ask the viewpager to
go return me those fragments now you
have to be a little bit careful here
because the way the viewpager works is
that it it actually will will
instantiate those fragments when it
needs to and it will keep bits and
pieces of them around depending on
whether you're using a fragment page
adapter or a fragment state page adapter
so there's two ways you can actually try
and fetch you know these fragments that
have been proved pre instantiating the
first is that when you instantiate the
fragment add it to your fragment manager
using a tag you know give it a name and
then you later on you can you can query
the framer manager to go return that
particular fragment the other way you
can do it is that when you instantiate
your fragments you can track it in your
own you know array or vector or map
yourself and hold onto it there so when
you need to go and fetch it you can go
and return the one that's already been
instantiated so that's question one
question two is what is the difference
between the the view flipper and the
view animator well the view animator is
actually the base class for the view
flip but so the view flippers is a
specialized version of the view animator
and it's it's really there so that you
can have a set of views that you can you
know really go from one to the next and
the next and have some sort of animation
play now so the view animator allows you
to specify things like which which
particular animation you want you want
to to use when you transition from one
view to the next and view flipper itself
actually specializes in the sense that
the main thing that it can do is that
you can actually say hey I want a
specific time interval go to the next
view automatically so you could say
maybe every five seconds it might be a
photo a photo gallery app right so you
might be wanting to show a slideshow so
you can say every five seconds go to the
next view so you know the view flipper
just kind of
provides some of that nice stuff for you
in terms of the timing and before we
just wrap that question up there is
actually something called a view
switcher as well the view switcher also
has a base class of view animator the
view switcher is special in that it only
supports two views whereas the view
flipper supports two or more now the
reason you might use a view switcher is
literally when you're just toggling back
and forth between those two views but
the view switcher also allows you to
specify your own view factory so by
doing that you can choose how you
instantiate her then use a factory
patented to implement it that way all
right thanks for the question I being
just switch back to the to the questions
and we have Jack when will Google
revised the API for serving maps on
fragments right now we have to resort to
work around using map activity and this
makes the code ugly to be honest this is
a this is a question that's incredibly
popular we get it all the time we don't
have anything to announce but it's
something that we the engineering team
is certainly looking at but they're just
there's no announcements around this so
right now you are you are you are stuck
with using the map activity okay next
question from vinil what is the optimal
way for adding multiple fragments under
a single tab in the tab view with
backtrack functionality on the back
button right now I'm facing an issue
with the back button when there are two
fragments loaded under signal single tab
for two tabs okay so I'm trying to make
sense of this Tony dear turn your onion
do you guys want to chime in on this one
at all well one thing about the back
button is for sure you need to add our
when you add those new fragments you
need to have them put into a trance
so that when when you went to use I hit
the back button it will roll back all
the changes that I think if that's if
that's the mouse questions so I'm
anywhere anything to add to that I
didn't quite get the last statement the
question yeah I don't yeah so yeah I
mean you have AP is available of add to
back stack to how you want to manage and
only that's something that goes through
a comment will actually go into the back
side so you can press back on it to go
to the previous record yeah and there's
also overrides that you can implement in
your activity to say on back button
pressed as well so if you want to
specialize even further just keep in
mind that that override came in to API
10 i want to say but it might have been
might have been a different API version
so but certainly add to back stack is
there the the only other thing that will
add is that we've made this a little bit
nicer in jellybean you can now specify
back stack navigation behavior through
xml so in your layout files you can
actually there's a there's an XML
attribute where you can say that
basically what you're saying is when you
when you're on this particular element
and you hit back which one should i go
to which you should go back to ok back
to the questions all right how do i make
my hardware device and they said HTC
available for testing instead of using
the emulator without sending my app to
the android market and I guess this
person means the Play Store now Tony do
you want to grab this one yeah sure arm
so in general you can do testing
development using Eclipse and using the
adt plugin so our for testing using a
real phone you need to enable USB
debugging on your phone I wonder whether
people can see this Oh No so yeah we can
see that yeah it is under setting so um
there is a option called enable USB
debugging so
to enable that you just plug your phone
through USB to your to your to your
laptop or desktop one thing about a
window involvement you may need to
install a driver are you for for that
and but other than that you can just use
Eclipse parking us pnt debug through
your wheel phone so cool thanks Tony
alright the next question is from Abby
again and I intentionally didn't cover
in my previous answer tin cover a
particular topic because I was waiting
for this question and it's basically
what's the difference between the
fragment pager adapter and the fragments
state pager adapter and also when should
either of them be used so basically what
it is is that the fragment pager adapter
when the fragments are no longer
required what it will do is relinquish
the view hierarchy for that for that
fragment but it'll keep the fragment
around in the case of the fragment
state-paid your adapter what it will do
is actually call save state on the
fragment and it will release the
fragment itself so when the frame once
again needs to be reinstated what it
will do is restore the state that it
that it saved earlier now that's a
reasonably subtle difference but
basically what it is it's about it's a
trade-off between performance versus
memory requirements memory usage sorry
so a fragment pager adapter because it
only really quizzes the view hierarchy
it stays resident in your app so it's
obviously consuming more memory but it
means that when that fragment is
required again it has to do less work to
go and show that fragment so that's one
that performs slightly better but
because it consumes more memory it's
less scalable and that's where the
fragment state pager adapter comes in
where if you have lots and lots of
fragments you're better off using the
state paid your adapter which is going
to be more aggressive about
relinquishing memory so it's a bit of a
trade-off see how many fragments you
you're expecting to have in your
app I wouldn't even say that there's a
magic number but have a look at it I say
if you've got more than a handful of
fragments that you're you're you're
displaying and then move to the state
Patriot after otherwise try and
otherwise stick with the just the pager
the fragrant pager adapter okay next
question considering I've been living
under a rock for the past six years geez
that sounds very uncomfortable but
however where do you guys recommend i
get started on developing for android
devices I knew it how about you take
this room you're on New York all right
so we have plenty of documentation and a
lot of resources on
developer.android.com you can go there
we have some Android you classes that
give you basics and just a lot of stuff
when what Android is and the framework
components and their own time and the
library is available to you so I think I
think just going to delivered on android
com is it would start also we have
plenty of videos on YouTube and there's
a lot of resources around which you can
check up I see I think that would be a
good place to start that'll be our
developer site yeah adding to that I
think in terms of designing enjoy style
avocation we have under under the carpet
or enjoy come with we have a specific
like session go / design so it has a
tons of information about how to design
a really enjoy of style application as
well so make sure you check that out in
terms of online resource stack overflow
there are a lot of questions answer
android question gets answered there so
you probably can find a lot of
uncircumcised ocupo as well yeah look
I've just shared the the entry point for
our developer.android.com training site
and you know over there we literally
show you how to build your your apps
from the ground up
so you know the only step that you need
to take prior to this is setting up your
development environment and again if you
go to the tools section you'll find it
there and you need some familiarity with
Java the rest of it the Android side of
it is you can learn about from from this
page here so this is this is the place
where I recommend everyone goes to
basically start learning okay now we
have Hemant on on the Hangout here
hemanth that have you got access to a
mic look okay so he's chatting and he's
asking some questions about is there an
easy way for remote debugging and looks
like I'd nerds been been working with
the time do you want to just walk us
through the question and the answer yes
so the question is unstirred trying to
understand what's the environment that
the payment has there so from what I can
gather he has a linux box and the device
is available over the internet so was
explaining there is ddms and adb these
are some of the tools that help you
connect to devices and adb can work over
ssh with port forwarding that's one way
to do a remote device so you may have
your device attached to it attached to a
laptop near you and your codebase lips
or your apk lives in a different machine
and you can use adb over ssh to deploy
remotely and debug there is also a DB
over tcp which allows you to connect to
a device over the same into over the
same subnet and adb OTC I TCP I think
requires you to plug in the cable first
and then say adb mode is TCP and then
you can plug the cable out and then use
the IP address to connect so and if
there are if there is something you want
to clarify about your environment please
go ahead and we can we can also based on
that yeah very cool um so he said it's
cool
okay that's that's fantastic next
question what is to stand on native
versus html5 apps again from em it's
live Tony would you like to take this
one um i guess like we really it it
really depends on your applications like
what time of features you need for our
for your particular application so the
strength of like native apps is you have
a tighter integration access to our
sensors in your phone and which html5 is
catching up but I thing is still like
native apps can do a better job in from
of assessing like different sensor on
you if that's what you what you need in
your particular application probably are
you you may want to consider more on
native at the html5 application of
cotton the benefit is you can we use
what you develop already offer for your
phone for a desktop web application so
we can use that we use a lot of the web
stuff you have already through webview
so it I guess it really depends on your
environment what you already have and
what kind of features we are planning to
you to add to your application yeah
might just just add on that that there
is no one-size-fits-all so when you ask
this sort of question I I can't say that
it's very you know clear-cut that you
should go one way or another depends
what's important to you depends what you
can put your priorities on certainly
native apps will tend to be very
responsive and they'll turn to be faster
I mean typical web technologies you know
tend to refresh the whole page and that
sort of thing so you can certainly put
the work in to your to your web app to
make it give a native experience or at
least give an experience that the user
is feels this is native but it depends
where you can commit those resources
yeah I guess another key thing is like
make sure you have an Android style app
I mean doesn't matter what technology
using ensure the user experience have
ever have a good android user experience
I think that's also very important yeah
so I guess tourney what you're referring
to are things like the action bar better
uses of the the the the back button and
those sorts of things that really give a
give it an android look available yeah
even the choice of graphics like icons
like we have our own style like buttons
and and think so um so make sure you you
you build an Android style application
in our platform yeah cool all right
thank you so um final question on the
moderator is how do I take a picture of
the content of the webview completely
and he's post today well it could be a
sheet they've posted a link to a stack
overflow page which is about
programmatically taking a screenshot of
the webview when that webview is
rendering a some flash content and what
the stack overflow thread said was that
it they were they were getting
effectively black boxes where the flash
content lives I actually don't know of a
way to do this I don't know if I never
thought Tony know how to do this but I
don't know of a way to capture that
flash content when you take a screenshot
oh yeah I have local either no yeah
sorry about that it's flashy it's one of
those specialized instance of Technology
and I suspect that you know through
various optimizations it's rendering in
ways that might make it harder for us to
for you to be able to grab these these
screenshots I would suggest have a look
at what happens when you do it through
DDMS you know through the Eclipse tools
if you can get away with that then that
might be
might be the solution you're looking for
it's certainly not programmatic there
there now Hemant wants to start a flame
war about whether html5 is going to be
flashier in the long term I think we try
to avoid controversial topic seven so uh
you know it's a matter of it's a matter
of opinion who knows I'm just going to
go back and check if there are any more
questions that have been posted on the
on the event it doesn't look like it
though and so is there anyone else
that's that's live that would that has
any questions all right well in that
case it's a fairly short one today
thanks for joining us thanks for tuning
in we'll be back again next time next
week same time and we look forward to
seeing you then we'll obviously post the
moderator link beforehand so make sure
you get those questions and we had some
interesting questions there's a fairly
technical answer keep them coming and on
that note thank you very much see you
like I said thank you alright bye